[Music]  netflix has been accused of reformatting  some of the films they stream uh to  their customers so that they they better  fit the screen and the result is movies  where scenes have been altered and  cropped in different ways well netflix  this is the accusation  netflix is denying that they'd ever  intentionally cut off portions of their  movies but it's really hard to argue  with the evidence check out this classic  scene from a few good men on  netflix jessup did you order the code  ray you don't have to answer that  question i'll answer the question  you want answers i think i'm entitled  you want i don't want the truth you  can't handle the truth  [Applause]  [Music]